طبعا هذه معلومات ايضا عن العرس مشاهدينا
الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني يبلغ من
العمر 29 عاما وهو الابن البكر للملك عبد
الله الثاني ابن الحسين من زوجته الملكه
رانيا العبد الله
وهو بحسب وفق خط الخلافه على العرش
الاردني هو الوريد لعرش المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه بعد ابيه الملك عبد الله الثاني
بن الحسين منذ بلوغه سن الرشد القانوني
عام 2012 تولى الاميره الحسين مسؤوليات
كثيره ورافق والده الملك عبد الله الثاني
في عدد من الزيارات الدوليه والمحليه
بالفعل انهى الحسين تعليمه ثانوي في مدرسه
كينجز اكاديمي في مادبا في الاردن حصل على
تعليمه الجامعي في التاريخ الدولي من جورج
تاون في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عام
2016 ايضا تخرج الاميره الحسين من
اكاديميه سانتوريرتست العسكريه الملكيه في
بريطانيا عام 2017 ويحمل رتبه نقيب في
القوات المسلحه الاردنيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات